the way gara uses his five magical signs
in the witcher series has changed
significantly from one game to the next
as have the skill trees assigned to each
sign to help guide you towards a combat
style that works for you we've compiled
a breakdown to show you the signs in
action at each of their five available
levels when you start the witcher 3 the
first level of each sign is available
afterwards you need to spend skill
points to level them up let's look at
hard one of the game's better crowd
control skills art unleashes a blast of
telekinetic energy that staggers your
enemies it's helpful in a number of
situations though most useful when
surrounded by a pack of creatures like
necker's drowners or wolves you can also
blast a flying enemy like a harpy out of
the air with a well-timed art burst
level two far-reaching art increases the
blasts range making it easier to pull
wyverns and harpies out of the air as
they swoop in for the kill level 3 Rd
sweep is the alternate sign mode which
takes the standard cone of effect and
makes it a circle around Geralt if
you're in the middle of a forest and
surrounded by white wolves you'll enjoy
the upgrade level 4 art intensity
increases the effectiveness of every
aspect of the sign every sign has an
equivalent passive enhancement level 5
shock wave increases the damage you do
when blasting opponents by this point
you could off a number of enemies in one
go flinging them outwards and plunging
your silver sword into them for a final
execution yrden slows enemies who enter
its area of effect this sign is vital
when facing ghostly enemies like noon
raids because it turns them corporeal
when they enter the traps area of
influence Heerden slowing effect also
makes it great for crowd control as well
as for making large enemies like
Cyclopes lumber about in slow motion
level two sustained glyphs make straps
last longer in addition when you
activate the next level of yerden you
get more chances to activate multiple
traps at once level three magic trap
adds a one-time damage effect and
increases the traps radius try dropping
yrden only when an enemy draws near to
inflict that damage and get the most out
of the trap level for your Dan intensity
does what it says on the tin it
intensifies the traps effects at level
four every sign has an intensity
increase like this level five
supercharged glyphs causes enemies to
lose health for every second they stand
within the trap if the creatures you
face are weak enough you can watch their
health siphon away without having to put
a lot of swinging effort in next up
Quinn Geralt protective shield Quinn
should be your first line of defense
when facing bosses and other big
monsters after all many of them can
slash away a good portion of your health
with a single hit but it's also really
helpful when you're facing a bunch of
drowners or wolves that keep knocking
you around before you can get in a swing
level to exploding shield pushes back
opponents when it breaks and it its most
powerful will knock enemies down level
three active shield causes your shield
to remain as long as you have enough
stamina also when the shield absorbs
damage you gain some health level for
Quinn intensity does what you probably
imagined it does it increases the
effectiveness of all of Quinn's
attributes level five when discharge
reflects damage the shield soaks up back
at your opponent interestingly enough
the most defense-oriented sign is the
one that frees you up to slash away with
abandon now let's look at Geralt most
charming sign ax e ax e charms an
opponent temporarily eliminating him
from combat not only does this allow you
to stun bandits and turn them against
each other at higher levels but it makes
available certain conversation options
outside of combat think of ax e is the
witcher's version of the Jedi mind-trick
level 2 delusion keeps opponents from
moving towards garel
they're charmed and at the highest tier
it staggers your victims even when the
charm fails level 3 puppet turns your
target from foe into friends for a
period of time keep in mind that this
doesn't make the victim any more
aggressive though if there isn't another
enemy in range your target won't go
looking for one level for AXI intensity
yep you guessed it it makes AXI even
more effective level 5 domination allows
you to stun and convert to opponents at
once
I mean why bother getting your boots
bloody if you can just make someone else
do your dirty work
and now let's take a look at pygmy pygmy
causes you to emit a blast of fire in
front of you what more can be said fire
is always fun and this is the best
offensive sign at your disposal
effective against almost any enemy you
face with only a few exceptions level to
melt armor causes Agni to well melt
armor making your victims more
vulnerable level 3 fire stream turns the
whoosh of fire into a continuous stream
of flames what a blast
oh god I'm doing puns again level 4
ignant entity you probably know what
this means a passive upgrade to your
fiery blasts level 5 pyromaniac
increases the chance of causing an enemy
to burn for a sustained period of time
by the way this of course applies
whether or not you're using fire stream
a simple blast towards a crowd of
bandits can quickly turn into a
veritable wienie roast so there you have
it a look at all five levels of all five
signs hopefully this helps you get the
most out of your adventuring in The
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt